c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche qu'est ce que tu fais là
bas jusqu'à marquer la casta ça castagne
ok je nique ta tête
pas les benjamins crevettes
il est
on axe
à
je m'appelais là non c'est pas un mec
t'as qu'à sa saga pokémon
ok ok ok enfin quoi ta gueule je suis à
la dame n'a pas suffi d'un petit cirque
un barracuda
si m
mais très 10 500
[Rires]
ça suffit ça ne me dit pas trop amoureux
c'est une cup chanceux espaces dans son
dos de ciani
quant aux rétais lesquels j'avais gagné
[Musique]